to a greater extent than we perhaps
realize when it comes to what sort of
relationships we're allowed to have our
society's present us with a menu with
only a single option on it the
monogamous cohabiting romantic
relationship usually served up with a
side order of children to be considered
remotely normal we are meant to develop
overwhelming emotional and sexual
feelings for one very special person who
will then become a combination of our
best friend soul sexual partner
co-parent business associate therapist
travel companion property co-manager
kindergarten teacher and soul mate and
with whom we will live exclusively in
one house in one bed for many decades in
substantial harmony and with an active
tolerance for each other's foibles and
an ongoing desire for their evolving
appearance till death do us part
but what is striking for an arrangement
supposed to be entirely normal is just
how many people cannot abide by its
rules at least half flunk completely and
a substantial portion muddle along in
quiet desperation at best only around
15% of the population
ever admit to being totally satisfied a
thought inducing lilo figure for a menu
option vigorously claiming Universal
validity in our societies those who
can't get on with romantic monogamous
marriage are quickly diagnosed as
suffering from a variety of
psychological disorders fear of intimacy
cleanliness sexual addiction frigidity
boundary issues self-sabotage childhood
trauma etc etc we powerfully imply that
someone might be psychologically ill if
they don't want to keep having sex
exclusively with the same partner or
seek to spend every other weekend apart
all want to develop a close friendship
elsewhere but there might be another
approach this one drawn from the
pioneering work of advocates of gay
rights namely that any taste or
proclivity must by definition be
acceptable and non-pathological except
in
so far as it might hurt an unwilling or
unconsenting partner from this
perspective while many ways of life
might be different to societies
presently preferred option it cannot be
right to judge correct amend and seek to
re-educate all those attracted to them
with us in mind the menu of love that we
should use starts to look very different
aside from romantic monogamy all kinds
of alternative ways of living could be
devised including to kick-start a list
the parenting relationship a union
oriented first and foremost towards the
well-being of children where parents are
free to form unions with other parties
once the welfare and security of
offspring are assured the separate
spheres relationship a union which
understands that no two people should
ever be expected to be in total
proximity night after night and respects
the role of certain kinds of privacy in
contributing to emotional well-being and
a robust sense of self but the yearly
renegotiated relationship a union which
is accepted by both parties as having
only a one-year assured lifespan after
which it must be renegotiated but
without any presumption that it will
necessarily be so all resentment if it's
not a source of insecurity with
surprisingly fruitful and even
aphrodisiac all side effects the love or
sex union a union which recognizes the
difficulty of fusing love and sex in one
couple and makes the possibility of
dividing the two and seeking fulfillment
from alternative sources non tragic
unsane full and a bit predictable in
love we accept an absence of choice that
would be intolerable in other areas of
life we consent to wearing as it were a
uniform that cannot possibly fit our
varied shapes and without daring to make
even minor moves to assemble our own
wardrobe all our collective energies go
into creating astonishing varieties of
foods machines and entertainments while
the entity that dominates our lives our
relationships continue in a form
more or less unchanged for the last 250
years it would be a genuine liberation
if whenever a new couple came together
it was assumed that they would almost
certainly not go along with the romantic
monogamous template and that the onus
was therefore on them to discuss upfront
in good faith and without insult the
arrangements that would ideally satisfy
their natures extra marks would be
awarded for innovation and
out-of-the-box schemes while
protestations of satisfaction at the
standard model would raise a few
eyebrows
once upon a time male offspring of the
European upper classes had only two
career options to join the army or to
join the church such narrow mindedness
was eventually dismissed as evident
nonsense and eradicated and the average
citizen of a developed country now has
at least 4,000 job options to choose
from we should strive for a comparable
expansion of our menus of love we are
not so much bad at relationships as
unable presently to understand our needs
without shame to stick up politely for
what makes us content and to invent
practical arrangements that could stand
a chance of honouring our complex
emotional realities visit our shop to
give a life-changing gift the School of
Life offers a wide range of thoughtful
practical and genuinely useful gifts
designed to help us solve some of the
most common and intractable problems of
life click now to learn more